we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i was
welcomed back back from our vacation
with hundreds and hundreds of voicemails
most unusable but some interesting
comments including this one inviting me
to join what the caller is describing as
the alt left let's take a look at that
what's up David I was just wondering if
you are interested in joining the alt
left uh we are against white people and
we're totally for gay people and against
straight people and we want to set up
the Jewish yes no state if you want to
join please give us a call thank you
well listen they didn't leave their
number so I'm not that's unfortunately
not going to be something I can take
them up on I find the entire alt left
thing to be pretty toxic and I'm not so
in the same way that remember we would
always talk about progressive left and
then eventually I said there are a
liberal enclaves on the left but the
term regressive left has become totally
perverted almost to be meaningless and
just kind of used as an ad hominem
against the left so I'm no longer gonna
use it and it's been a very very long
time since we've used that term
regressive left because I think the term
has effectual effectively been drained
of any value for the purposes of
political discussion all left also was
created as a sort of ad hominem which is
okay listen the alt-right
is a perversion of the right but the
left has its own perversion of the left
called the out left we never used the
term and I don't even think it got
enough pickup to be worthy of a
long-form piece sort of explaining what
it is we did a long-form piece on the so
called regressive left before we wrote
off the term all together all left from
the get-go was basically an ad hominem
okay there is some horrible stuff
happening on the left celebration of
authoritarian regimes in Venezuela total
haphazard denial of what's going on with
Russia irrational Israel hatred that
goes over the line into anti-semitism of
course criticism of Israeli policy not
being by definition anti-semitism I want
to be super
about that this sort of indifference to
Assad in Syria there are conspiracy
theorists as well and left all of that
stuff exists but I'm not going to jump
into using the term alt left for it
because I think that it's not a
productive way to describe it so just to
get caught up to speed here please no
one really identifies themselves as alt
left it's used entirely as a pejorative
because you know the alt right is an
actual movement we're proud to call
themselves alt right it's not the same
with the left I think that you're right
I mean I've never seen anyone
self-identify as alt left which is
obviously why this voicemail is
ridiculous I has actually seen anybody
self-identify as part of the alt left
not satirically not in a way to sort of
attack the movement I don't know let me
know but to answer the question from the
caller I guess I have no interest
whatsoever in joining the alt left and
please never ask me about it again on
the bonus show today we've got a great
bonus show we will hear from Pat about
what he did on his vacation I've got a
bunch of great vacation show stories
that I will tell and I think that the
audience is going to find themselves
titillated and riveted by many of these
stories two ways to get access to the
bonus show number one become a member a
david pakman.com slash membership number
two become a patron for at least five
bucks a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we'll speak to you then